i would be working a you know doing a
shoot and we'd finish at you know three
or four in the morning and then about
six in the morning i'd be at starbucks
you know you want foam on your latte
jay we had this comment come in on our
youtube channel the other day and i
wanted to read it for you and please
you're welcome to jump in at any time it
goes i made my first and only 16
millimeter feature film in 1997 that
cost me around fifty thousand dollars
that i paid for out of my own pocket
used credit cards and borrowed money
from my parents
however unlike rodriguez and smith my
film was a complete and total failure i
wasn't accepted into any film festivals
and wasn't able to get any sort of
distribution
this cost me financially including my
future in having a career as a filmmaker
and 25 years later i'm still dealing
with the debt and financial instability
from it
fifty thousand is a lot of money for
most people let alone 5 million for a
film
the reality for myself and i know there
are other aspiring filmmakers who've
gone down the same path like i did that
you only have got one shot
and if you fail both financially and
commercially no one is going to invest
in you or another film because why would
they
no one invests in failed filmmakers
so like here's what i'll say to that i
and i don't like i know where he's
coming from but he's also coming from a
completely like a different time 1997
shooting on film
yes yeah that probably did cost a
minimum of 50 grand to get something in
the can but um
today
it doesn't like it doesn't cost that
much to make it doesn't have to cost
that much to make a feature film and it
when when we set ourselves up that hey i
got one shot and it's this and it's over
like it almost is never gonna work out
in in my experience like filmmaking is a
numbers game you know the people that
that
you know break out like get discovered
and like take off on their first films
the rodriguez and the tarantino's and
spike lee and all them
they're lottery winners like like that
that is not the norm
most filmmakers that i know i know very
few that did well in their first movie
like almost almost none i like i can't i
can't name any i didn't actually on the
movies that i produced it took me maybe
four films before i was making like a
profit
you know but again i wasn't spending 50
000
today
you know
you just you just got to
you know set a smaller scale for what
you're shooting but you you can shoot a
feature film for twenty thousand dollars
you can shoot a feature film for ten
thousand dollars you know if you're
smart you know if you pull in favors you
have gear you can you can do these
things we have our we have i have a
phone in my pocket that has a better
camera on it than the cinema cameras
that i did my first like two or three
movies on
you know so today i i just i think that
that
i think that one of the biggest problems
with indie filmmakers they're still
looking at the filmmaking landscape like
it was 97 like it was 2005 and it's not
it's a completely different time you
know there has never been a a point in
history where it's so easy to make
movies it can be so cheap to make movies
and it's easy to get them out there like
on professional platforms you know now
you know on the downside of that is
everybody can make movies and there's a
lot of content and we can get into that
later but
i i i i don't think it's an all or no it
should never be an all or nothing like
i'm all in on this and that's it um for
for me you know
if that's the path someone chooses to
take you know more power to them but
i personally think it's a numbers thing
if you make five movies
two are gonna fail you know one or two
are gonna break even and that fifth one
is going to make enough to cover the
other
four
you know
excellent and and
there's more of this comment and you
know i appreciate this person for being
candid enough to oh totally and i think
you do too
and i feel like this is probably
unfortunately a common story and i've
heard from people that have spent
actually double that oh yeah for their
first film and yeah and we're in debt
and
so yeah it's um
i appreciate them for for leaving this
um the fact is movies cost money and
they're a team effort and no one working
on a film should work for free
even though you can now shoot a movie on
an iphone the fact is not everyone can
afford an iphone
people like this guy and the commenter
is referring to some more interviewing
like to talk about how easy it is
nowadays and use what you have access to
but not everyone has access to the
things people take for granted
i certainly don't have the money to make
another film heck i wouldn't even edit
anything on my 15 year old computer
which i'm still using because i can't
afford anything newer
people with money or access to money
have no idea what it's like when you're
living paycheck to paycheck which is
most filmmakers these days who are not
already established
so i
yeah yeah i have a lot of empathy uh for
that statement and i i do and i also
with everything i just said i you know i
want to you know make known that i do
realize my my privilege you know i i did
not come for money you know i we we come
from minimum wage you know i i've paid
for everything myself but
i'm a healthy white male
i i've i've had a fairly easy go of it
comparatively um
but
that said i i
you know when i made my first movie um
you know
this was
2003 uh that we shot at summer 2003 and
i
was working at starbucks um you know so
i was making i don't know five minimum
wage whatever it was and some tips i
worked 35 hours a week and i was paying
for college you know um i was still able
like in that situation to save a little
bit of money myself and
get a little bit on a credit card and
you know i think that first movie we
made for about four thousand dollars
you know and it was me and a couple
other friends and we kind of came
together on it and put it together and i
know there are people that are in a
position where you know they can't even
like do that
you know with their you know you know
people that start families early um you
know or uh somebody that's disabled or
somebody that has you know other
responsibilities i was a young
single
white guy and i didn't you know i had
nothing to do but save up my money and
pay for my college you know so
but all that said
it doesn't take that i think people set
up roadblocks for themselves when it
comes to making movies because you know
it's a scary thing
and i think sometimes people it's easier
just to say hey like it's too hard i'm
not gonna do it
then to like buckle down and do it
you know and i like i i buckled down you
know and then and after that movie and
that movie didn't make much money and i
was still broke and i was driving a 91
ford explorer and katrina happened and i
loaded up my explorer and with what i
had left and i drove across country to
la and you know i surfed on a friend's
couch for about six months
and i couldn't get a job i started
working at starbucks again and
the entire i worked at starbucks through
my first one two three four for my first
five movies you know so like i i would i
would work i would save up a little bit
money i would shoot and then i'd save up
a little bit more money and i would
shoot again you know i would i would be
working a you know doing a shoot and
we'd finish at you know three or four in
the morning and then about six in the
morning i'd be at starbucks you know you
want foam on your latte you know but but
like those are the kind of things if you
want to do it
if you are healthy
and you don't have
you know you know
four kids
you can make it work if you choose to
make it work i i believe in
general and
so you were living in louisiana at the
time that you were you were paying for
college working at starbucks there yes
and you managed to do that and then once
katrina hit
you moved here you drove
and
would you ever run into people that you
were
working with on set while you were at
starbucks oh yeah yeah it's so like
yeah so that i would be i remember i was
on uh my first movie and uh the the
first weekend we shot we had a really
big day it was kind of a
apocalyptic zombie movie so we had this
sequence set up in a self-storage
facility and we had like
oh man something like 40 extras i mean
it looked big you know and we were all
in college so you know we had a lot of
college friends come and help so we had
a fairly like impressive looking crew
and there was all these people here it
looked like a big deal you know and then
um one and one of the one of the zombies
you know i was talking to and then like
the next day um you know
and i say nothing about working at
starbucks like oh yeah you know i'm a
big time filmmaker and then you know the
very next day they right in the
drive-through and they kind of look they
did a double take and
they didn't say nothing but it it was
yeah
yeah and i had that happen many times
sure sure
that was in louisiana or here that was
in louisiana okay
in l.a it honestly i can't think of a
situation where it happened because i
you know when i when i moved to la i was
working at starbucks in downtown burbank
and you know i was shooting in you know
hawthorne or hollywood and i just i just
didn't i don't remember running to
anybody there but i may have
been there
yeah